In the latest version of our suburban scene, we had a moving car and a moving
dog. But of course really we want all the dogs and cars to move. One way of
doing that would be, instead of just making one car and dog move, to put all
the cars and dogs into an array list of movable objects. But you might say we
already have an array list of drawables, can't we reuse that? We can, but we
have to learn a bit more about working with types and Java. Let's say I have a
drawable, what I'd like to know is if it's a movable. The instanceof test gives
me the answer to that. This expression is true, if d happens to belong to a
class that also implements the moveable interface. Of course in that case, I'd
like to then call the move method. But not so fast, I can't call d.move because
d is not movable. I have to convert d to something that is movable. Here is how
you do that in Java. This expression means take d and cast it into a movable.
We've previously seen the cast notation to change a floating point number into
an integer, it's the same notation but now with an interface type. Once it is a
movable, then it is saved in the variable of type movable. And then we can
invoke the move method on m. Again you couldn't have invoked on d because d
doesn't have a move method, that's drawable. This conversion is necessary. What
if you make a cast of something that wasn't movable such as a house then he
would get an exception and your program would terminate. That's why it's
important that we first check whether d in fact is movable. These instances of
tests and casts are not very common but they do happen every so often. And it's
good to be familiar with them. So go ahead and put this to work. In the scene
program, go through all of the drawables. Find out which of them are moveable,
and move them.